[Musique]
une visite de terrain tourner vers l'est
et plus particulièrement le
développement de l'est c'est dans ce
contexte que la présidente du
département nassimah dindar s'est rendu
à saint-andré pour signer une convention
cadre entre le département et la commune
objectif la mise en place d'un projet de
développement social économique
territoriale à travers le réaménagement
le développement d'un site de loisirs
très fréquenté dans l'est le parc du
colosse
une signature qui s'est faite en
présence de jean paul virapoullé maire
de saint-andré et de jean marie
virapoullé vice président du conseil
départemental le départ nous avons la
compétence de l'association et donc nous
avec la mairie de saint-andré signé une
convention de partenariat pour former 10
et andré 1 pour apprendre à travailler
sur le bois de goyavier sur levallois
pour un peu un abus
embellir ce site du colosse l'embellie à
l'aménager avec un vrai projet global
qui va aller de la construction du
mobilier urbain de petits manques
adoubait l'embellissement avec avec pio
ce qui sont ici présents nous avons été
vu sur saint-andré plus humain et
saint-andré plus dynamiques sur le plan
économique
le cola symbolise mieux que tout autre
équipement
cette double vocation du mandat que le
peuple nous a confié
ce que le colosse est à la fois le
commente touristique de la ville
et c'est aussi grâce à la volonté de la
présidente du conseil départemental
madame dindar et de son vice président
jean marie verra privé c'est le plaisir
de vous accueillir un réaménagement qui
permit sera l'échelle départementale de
développer le tourisme
il faut aussi selon la présidente un
équilibrage du territoire et l'est est
une priorité
un chantier d'insertion sera mise en
place pour ce chantier qui sera
l'occasion de valoriser la filière bois
de goyavier puisque les aménagements les
équipements sont réalisés dans ce
matériau d'un matériau qu'on appelait
avant pestes végétales et puis ces âmes
à kaihori
et donc là d'une peste végétale faire
sortir des produits finis un petit
meuble un objet de décoration qu'on
amène à la case oui c'est une cape est
d'abord parce que il ya en même temps de
la transmission du savoir faire presque
le responsable jean françois rault à
former des jeunes et des moins jeunes il
a transmis à savoir vers locales et
ancestrale le bois de goyavier mise à
l'honneur également dans la ville de
saint-andré à proximité des travaux de
sécurisation de la route départementale
48 route de salazie sur cette portion
circulent plus de 14000 véhicules par
jour mais on y rencontre également des
piétons et des écoliers des trottoirs et
places de stationnement une piste
cyclable font partie des aménagements
ce sont des travaux de sécurité pour les
piétons
on a fait des trottoirs on est à aux
abords d'établissements scolaires une
école primaire ici
un lycée plus bas une autre école
primaire un peu plus bas donc il fallait
sécuriser le passage des piétons il y
avait des fossés à ciel ouvert ici donc
ce sont des travaux importants pour nos
enfants
huit cent mille euros ont été alloués
pour ces travaux financés à hauteur des
deux tiers par le département c'est une
première tranche y aura trois tranches
de travaux pour poursuivre la
réalisation de ces trottoirs et assurer
la sécurité de nos enfants
pour finir dans la lignée des grands
chantiers initiés par le département
le forage du désert qui a pour but
d'améliorer les connaissances géologique
et hydrogéologique sur le secteur de
saint-andré ce chantier débuté en
novembre 2015 s'est achevée en juin 2016
et a permis de délimiter 4 phase de
forage selon les profondeurs différentes
de localiser les arrivées d'eau et de
faire des essais de pompage par paliers
pour définir la qualité de nous le
forage a donc été inaugurée par la
présidente et fait l'objet d'une
convention de mise à disposition à la
commune
coût de l'opération pour la collectivité
968 1000 euros
[Musique]